[Music]
[Applause]
yes take us back fergie i grew up loving
fergie like she literally inspired me
fergie makes a surprise appearance
during jack harlow's first class
performance at the vmas and the crowd's
reaction
is priceless
[Applause]
[Music]
i have the best fans ever because they
really have my back they are loyal and
they are like family fergie's appearance
even had taylor swift jamming in her
seats smiling from ear to ear
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
jack opened the show with his hit song
which samples fergie's 2006 hit
glamorous
check out the rapper walking through a
replica of a plane packed with celeb
passengers like becky g chloe bailey and
lil nazex
i got plaques in the mail peak season
shout out to my ups workers making sure
i receive it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and jack gives fergie an epic intro
ladies and gentlemen fergie
then things get should we say
fergalicious
[Applause]
[Music]
when i was in fifth grade i tried to
perform fergalicious at the talent show
i love i have like a strong artistic
connection to fergie
so i've been wanting to do that for a
while and it just came together and i
figured
it's time the world it would be
refreshing the world i'm curious
how many kids know that or if this is
their first you know because i was a kid
when i was out well the success of first
class and the crowd's reaction at the
vmas proves just how timeless of a song
glamorous is
speaking of timeless fergie stuns next
to jack as she rocks a silver skirt and
top with the words first class in red
i just want people to enjoy it have fun
replay it and that's exactly what's
happening
[Applause]
because this performance right here
is one to remember
[Applause]
[Music]
you